non
les pilotes d'avions d'occasion
invisible le fameux avion invisible
américain qui transporte la bombe
atomique
puis d'un seul coup tu es en l'air et
puis le manche à balai ennemis ou tu
peux plus le diriger cet avion et tu vas
tu écrasé mais tu as quand même le choix
de t'écraser soit sur new york soissons
moscou qui l'écrasent aux questions
qu'on a très content je n'ai je pas mais
je peux pas dire au mieux
ait fana séance axée qu'on sait très
content ce genre tu pourras faire ton
père ou tom un chablis génériques pour
un thé obligé d'apprendre par moscou
alors à bon bah oui la réponse foudre au
hasard si tu mourrais tu préfères être
incarné ans marguerite duras ou en
marilyn monroe
ah bon ah oui tu préfères la beauté que
l'intelligence mais je n'ai rien prouvé
qu'elle était content
alors imaginons que ton mec te trompes
c'est un jeu qu'est ce que tu fais tu
lui perce les yeux à perceuse électrique
du couple le sexe l'abstentionnisme
qu'est ce tu lui fais je les toiles de
mon mépris frais jeu plus est c'est lui
c'est pas bien méchant méchant je serai
plus gêné s'y trouvait au lit avec un
autre maître ou avec deux signes sa
version wifi serait plus ce serait très
gêné c'est une très glossy
non moi je vous dirais que trouver qu'un
autre mais ça serait plus normal
et toi c'était obligé de faire l'amour
obligé sous la sous la menace d'une arme
tu préféré le faire avec une jolie
silhouette comme avec les ailes car nick
clegg
ah bon oui ce défi ce nom ça presque
pour coucher avec un avantage pas
vraiment
toujours dans la série amour dînatoire
tu es obligé qui préfèrent faire l'amour
avec bar giscard ou chirac voyage jusqu
à barran pékin est bon d'être s'ils
n'ont pas joué parce que j'avais le cas
il est pas mal et chirac n'est pas mal
mais il faut choisir de montchoisi ont
été obligés de choisir
eh ben jusqu alors ouais
alors imagine que j'adopte des enfants
qui préférait adopter des jumeaux
cleptomane des jumelles pyromane est
merveilleux ces questions oui c'est le
vent qui se posera pas c'est vrai tu
attends là deux jumelles pyromane ou
deux jumeaux qu'alstom a exactement quel
côté tu écris c'est plus rigolo les
jumeaux keith bowman parce qu au moins
ils ramèneront des trucs à la malchance
est-ce que tu serais prêt à mourir
s'apprête à mourir pour que y ait plus
jamais de chômeurs en france sinon tu as
tout de suite non non je suis pas prêt
pour ça pourquoi moi pour les jeunes
pourquoi tu es prête à mourir par
exemple ok puis jamais d'inondations
bangladesh de patin moura je suis pas
prête à fait prête à mourir pour rien du
coup rien du tout non même si plus
jamais de pauvres sur la terre pour les
chefs de mission il faut que ça aille
très vite alors ce qui dégoûte le plus
c'est la scatophilie la nécrophilie
alors la catho philippe c'est quoi ces
gens qui mangent les des eaux et les
choses et vous temps et la nécro fils
était gentiment le désengorgement des
cas là c'est ce que les et située
seulement celle établie à la crise qu
témoins à micro philly au moi c'est de
la viande blanche la voir morte alors à
bon oui nous allons mais sur le fond
c'est bien donc c'est la microphysique
qui préfèrent manger un câble av que
manger des extrêmes parce que si je
mourais de faim par exemple je mangerais
bien akaddar je mens je crois pas que je
mangerai
et chose en dernière question con tu
pars sur un vaisseau spatial pour un
voyage qu'il a duré à peu près 4 50 voix
c'est long et que tu peux amener un seul
passage et enfin le client c'est une
passagère est-ce que tu m'aimes tu
préfères france gall ou café de la moi
je connais mieux katrina de france gall
je crois que j'aimerais mieux catherine
la très clair ça se passe et louis
latapie
avant tu croyais et j'y vois aussi le
petit pois attention nous battrons cela
revient avec catherine je dis pas qu'on
se marre pas bien avec france promet
beaucoup moins bien donc ces coffrets de
l'avant dans quatre ans en quatre ans
avec un petit train mayer